Starbucks uses gay semen in their coffee  to make it taste good where did that  come from these tend to love other each  other's semen and it flavors up the  coffee they like the taste of it it  flavors it up what does that mean it  flavors it up there's no doubt about  that at what point are they collecting  the semen where when are they inserting  it in my drink right oh it's already in  the process it's already in the pipeline  it's a process guys it's a pipeline you  know it's just it's a pipeline it's a  process it's it's in you can't it's just  it can't be removed not a way Starbucks  has already have just introduced a flat  white  uh drink latte or mocha I'm not sure  it's a latte it is that's a cover for  semen right it is eerily uh it is if  they're almost mocking me right like  they're saying the flat white guys that  was the drink that's the drink